just when you thought the news out of
washington could not get any worse i am
going to send a chill down your spine
with three simple words
president kamala
harris
this is a real possibility
it is not just coming from the fevered
nightmares of conservatives
it is actually being predicted by the
sitting president
and i can say as much as i want from the
time my
two daughters were born that you can do
anything a man can do
it's one thing for somebody to say that
and keep pounding that in the head of
their five granddaughters as well but
guess what
until they see it
till they watch
it becomes real then
that's why by the way she's it happens
to be in asia for me right now but
that's why we have a female vice
president of united states america who's
going to be we're going to have some
presidents pretty soon
we're going to and we're going to have
some presidents pretty soon that would
be a change of pace wouldn't it i think
joe biden meant to say we're going to
have female presidents pretty soon
pretty soon
does joe biden know something that we
don't know
that would also be a first biden
apparently does not know how many
americans are stranded in afghanistan he
doesn't know how much of our military
equipment the taliban now owns he
doesn't know exactly who we're flying
into america from the most violent
country on earth in fact the only thing
that we seem to know for certain right
now about our politics is that things
are likely going to get much
much worse i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knoll show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from ryan weiss who
says when michael was talking about the
woman on twitter crying about cutting
her son out of her life because he voted
for trump my first thought was i didn't
know my mom was on twitter lol you know
it's funny i mentioned this yesterday
about a woman crying as she couldn't
speak to her own
son anymore her beloved son just because
he voted for the other political party
and i thought this has to be a joke this
has to be a troll but then i had a
number of people write into me saying
that this described their families
too pretty pathetic stuff i just want
some relief from all this crazy tension
and when i want relief i turn to relief
band do you ever find yourself nauseated
i often feel nauseated reading the news
these days but you can be nauseated also
by i don't know morning sickness you can
be nauseated by hangovers you can be
nauseated by migraines i get a number of
migraines relief band that's the way to
deal with it's the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband it's been
clinically proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
from all sorts of things anxiety
chemotherapy right down to the regular
old hangover the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy and provides
all-natural long-lasting relief with
zero side effects for as long as needed
relief band stimulates a nerve in your
wrist so it stimulates this nerve that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea it's incredible
technology developed for use in
hospitals if you've ever tried a cheap
imitator don't forget about that this is
the one it's actually fda cleared it's
unbelievable stuff and no drugs right
now relief band has an exclusive offer
for our listeners go to reliefband.com
use promo code knowledge you'll save
twenty percent off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30 day money
back guarantee
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d dot com use promo
code knowles for 20 off plus free
shipping joe biden
says pretty soon we're gonna have some
presidents pretty soon we're gonna we're
gonna have a pro
[Music]
at which which would be not just having
a first woman president but just having
any president at all because it seems
that the guy who ostensibly is in the
job right now is asleep at the wheel it
has been days and days and days since
the taliban took down kabul took down
the afghan government within
11 days of us really beginning to pull
out and the question remains how many
americans are trapped there in
afghanistan
biden has given multiple
press conferences they're supposed to be
press conferences the problem is he
doesn't answer any questions from the
press 31st of redline how many hey i
know you're you're just trying to tell
us all to wear the masks and stuff and
get the jab but
what about all the thousands of
americans in afghanistan and you know
what often will happen so biden is just
bolting after he gives his statements he
just bolts these days because he can't
answer any of the questions but what has
happened in the past with biden is he'll
give his statement he doesn't want to
take questions from the press he starts
to bolt and then he'll hear a question
and he'll realize oh this is going to
make me look weak and he'll stop and
he'll turn around he's done this
multiple times in front of the white
house he can't do that here
not only because he knows that this is
extremely politically damaging for him
the afghanistan debacle but also because
he just doesn't know
no one seems to know
how many americans there are in
afghanistan initially we were told
you know a few thousand then it became
more like five or seven thousand and we
were told it's as many as ten or even
fifteen thousand but we're not being
given the number and now gen saki
spokes woman at the white house
is saying that there are no americans
stranded in afghanistan does the
president have a sense that most of the
criticism is not of leaving afghanistan
it's the way that he has ordered it to
happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not we
are committed to bringing americans who
want to come home home we are in touch
with them via phone via text via email
via any way that we can possibly reach
americans to get them home if they want
to return home there are no american
stranded is the white house's official
position on what's happening in
afghanistan i'm just calling you out for
saying that we are stranding americans
in afghanistan when i said when we have
been very clear that we are not leaving
americans who want to return home we are
going to bring them home now this is a
very clever trick
it's it's not all that clever because
it's so transparent but it's it's at
least clever in theory
jen saki is being asked a question by
peter ducey one of the last reporters
left in america
and the question is
what about these americans who are
stranded in afghanistan
and jansaki says
we are not
going to strand any americans in
afghanistan
you see that he's saying in the present
tense what about the americans currently
right now undeniably stranded in
afghanistan
and she says no no there will not be
anyone ultimately who is stranded in
afghanistan the question isn't about
your promises gensake the question isn't
about your predictions frankly the white
house's predictions on afghanistan have
been pretty bad they've been completely
wrong actually
and even the president has admitted that
and the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff has admitted that and
basically everybody involved in this
evacuation has admitted that all their
predictions turned out to be false they
didn't even think it was possible that
it would go this bad so please for a
moment spare me your assurances and your
predictions about what will happen in
the future what about the americans
stranded right now
no we will not strand
any americans in afghanistan oh really
like you won't lose all of our
protective equipment and have it taken
over by the taliban like you won't lose
the kabul embassy like you won't like
you won't like you won't give me a break
like you won't prevent americans from
being caught there in the first place
give me a break
by the way two hours prior to jen saki's
preposterous statement politico reports
that the pentagon confirmed
another mission to rush rescue americans
stranded in kabul
that's the language from politico
actually the verb or in this case the
adjective stranded
pentagon confirms latest mission to
rescue americans stranded
in kabul
listen to how they do it this is this is
uh in in politico apart from that
mission
a pentagon spokesperson john kirby said
at a news briefing monday that there had
been quote at least one additional
instance where rotary airlift was used
to help americans get from outside the
airport into the airport he declined to
elaborate further saying i think i'm
just going to have to leave it at that
today
they used
rotary air lift
what is
rotor what well there's only two this is
three ways to get something into the air
there's an airplane there's a rocket
ship and there's a helicopter
and this one's rotary
so it's not a jet it's not like fixed
wind oh it's a oh it's a helicopter oh
you're talking about a helicopter but
you don't want to use the word
helicopter because helicopter evokes
those images out of vietnam out of the
fall of saigon
the worst american foreign policy
debacle
until now
oh that's so they're going to use all of
these youth as always the left is going
to use all of these euphemisms they're
going to try to redefine all the words
they're going to try to use
mealy-mouthed jargon they're going to
try to play around with verbs and
adjectives to try to pretend that
americans are not currently stranded
like they're not being evacuated as fast
as they can though most experts think
there's not nearly enough time before
the august 31st deadline
to get the americans out
of afghanistan
meanwhile
while we can't get the people we want
out of afghanistan
some
prominent members of the blob of the
liberal establishment the deep state
are suggesting that we send some
americans into afghanistan because we
don't want them in our country anymore
the former director of both the cia
and the nsa
these are two very clandestine
operations involved in spying and
actually spying on americans in some
cases
michael hayden was sent to tweet
the tweet was can we send the maga
wearing unvaxxed to afghanistan no you
sending the plane back empty hayden
responds good idea
good idea so
one of the men to whom we gave
more power
to spy on
not just foreigners but also americans
than
anyone has ever had in american history
just about
he is now
openly
calling for deporting conservatives
because he doesn't like concern and not
even just conservatives by the way
so he's got the mega-wearing part but
they saying unvaxxed so if you
don't want to take the experimental drug
for the virus that doesn't pose a
particularly significant risk to most
people
you are
worthy of deportation we don't want you
in our country
and people with an outrageous amount of
power and who have had very prominent
roles in the government
want to ship you over to a war zone they
want to get
afghans out afghans who are largely
unvetted which we'll get to in a second
they want to get them out and bring them
into america to replace you because you
conservative or you person who even
objects to to being forced to take an
experimental drug
you are going to go live under the
taliban they hate you they don't like
you the ruling class doesn't want to
come to a reconciliation meet in the
middle shake hands and hug they hate
your guts they think that you are a
terrorist they think that you are a
murderer they think that you are less
than human deplorable irredeemable
bitter clinging bible thumping and they
want you
out you know
you know what i want in
bio-optimizers there's a zillion reasons
why you can't get enough sleep even
though you're supposed to get
seven hours a night at least seven hours
a night one of the biggest reasons
actually might be magnesium deficiency
magnesium is key to getting good sleep
but 75 of people are actually magnesium
deficient so is it any wonder that so
many people have sleep problems to help
fix sleep problems and to fully enjoy
the calming effects of magnesium check
out magnesium breakthrough by bio
optimizers it's the only organic full
spectrum magnesium supplement that
includes seven unique forms of magnesium
for instance you got marie she left a
five-star review she said i'd give this
100 stars if i could within one month of
use i went from daily struggles with
restless legs horrible terrible sleep to
no struggles with any of that i know it
sounds dramatic and far-fetched but it's
true magnesium breakthrough is 100
organic it's made with vegetarian
non-gmo ingredients give it a try right
now check out for yourself why so many
people are raving about magnesium
breakthrough for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to magbreakthrough.com
knowles use knowles 10 during checkout
to save 10
the war on the unvaxed the unclean the
unwashed
continues of pace now it's not just
preening
liberals on the coasts or people in the
academy
or
people even in the media
washington establishment
it's medical doctors
even medical doctors now
are throwing hissy fits
because some people don't want to take
an experimental drug
that
is supposed to fight off a virus that
for most people is not particularly
dangerous
but actually apparently doesn't even
really prevent infection
all that well it it i suppose it
ostensibly prevents the more serious
effects of infection
but it doesn't according to the science
doesn't really prevent transmission
doesn't really prevent infection
according to certain studies you
actually have the same viral load if
you're vaccinated or unvaccinated
doctors in florida 75 of them
are walking off the job
to protest their unvaccinated patients
and the left-wing media
are cheering them on just moments ago
more than 75 doctors staged a walkout to
protest the number of covet patients
coming to the hospitals who have not
been vaccinated the thing hey let's
bring in kerry sanders because carrie
you're in palm beach gardens florida at
this doctor's walkout
carry with and i know the area very well
what americans don't understand is for
every unvaccinated person that's filling
up an icu bed that means with a
hospital's jam somebody with a heart
attack and i've known somebody in this
position goes there has trouble getting
in can't get treatment can't get a bed
it is a nightmare for the doctors it is
a nightmare for the nurses and to the
doctor's
point of view
it's worse yet for sick people that want
help from them that is truly reflective
of the frustration that you see behind
me and these doctors have gathered some
coming off their shifts to come out here
gathering to try to tell people please
first of all ignore the nonsense and the
absurdities that you're hearing people
say at public meetings and recognize the
value of what a vaccine will do it's
about time it's about time that these
doctors finally summon the courage to
refuse to treat sick people you know
i've been waiting for it for for a long
time basically since the hippocratic
oath was written
that oath that the doctors take to do no
harm and to do their best to do justice
to to their patients
because some people
they just they just don't care they they
inconsiderately get sick and then they
expect what the doctors are just
supposed to take care of them
i just i wish that the doctors would
take it further
and also stage a walk out
and refuse to treat all those fatties
you know all those fatties who show up
because those fatties they show up and
they they have heart problems sometimes
you know or they've got sometimes they
have diabetes
sometimes they have all sorts of
vascular issues and they're taking up
hospital beds from the good skinny
people
you know
or the gay guys for instance they really
the doctors need to go out and protest
with the gay guys and refuse to treat
them because the gay guys are
statistically at a greater risk of
contracting hiv and aids so
if they if they contract those
that virus and that turns into oh
they're going to take up a sick bed from
a good not gay guy right so
it's just in the interest of medicine
and public health
it's about time the doctors refuse to
treat
aids patients right
or or smokers for instance
it's a tough one for me big fan of
cigars but you know in in fairness for
justice
the doctors need to refuse to treat
these smokers because what happens
smokers sometimes devel there is a risk
they will develop on occasion or even
more than on occasion
health problems heart disease lung
problems mouth problems and they'll take
up hospital beds
oh hold on that's that's their job right
that's the job of the doctors to treat
the sick people but the doctors don't
want to do that
because the doctors don't understand
what they're doing because none of us
really understands what we're doing
because we have lost
the philosophical and political
sophistication
to discuss these matters because all
that is left
is fear-mongering and contempt
and disdain for our countrymen
specifically for
conservatives the only group that you
are allowed
to vilify
in public
even more so people will vilify men for
being men in the patriarchy or they'll
vilify white people for white white
supremacy and whiteness is terrible but
you know they'll they'll also vilify
women when they go along with
conservatives i think sarah palin or
somebody like that they'll also vilify
black guys if they go along with
conservatives like larry elder we'll get
to that in a second
so
it's really just the conservatives
who should not receive medical treatment
who should be shipped over to live under
the taliban and very likely be killed in
a war zone
now on the topic of the vaccine
there might be one political benefit to
this hysteria over the vaccine and this
hysteria over the coronavirus more
broadly
it's
if it is not exposing for the left
its own hypocrisy on other political
issues it's at least exposing it for a
lot of us
there's a new york city councilman mark
d levine
he is a city councilman in new york and
he wants to remind you
that the new
vaccination screening program
for various indoor activities
requires here well i'll just use his own
words new york city's new vaccination
screening program for indoor dining etc
requires that you show proof of vacs
and
asterisks
id
if you have an id don't forget to bring
it
if you need an id
get the city's idnyc available
to all including undocumented here's how
to get yours and he includes the link
didn't realize we had george wallace on
the new york city council didn't realize
david duke
was able to get himself elected down in
new york
id
you you expect new york which has a
substantial black population you expect
that new yorkers can get ids to go
indoors all right woolworth's lunch
counter all over again i guess
black people can't get id's the
democrats have been telling me that for
years so now you're now you can't go
into a restaurant if you don't have an
id
pretty soon we're going to have
different water fountains if this guy
has his way right
or the ids have nothing to do with rice
he goes on he explains what the idea is
for the idea requirement is to help
reduce fraud
hold on well
i'm gonna have to read this again the
idea requirement says democrat new york
city councilman mark levine is to help
reduce fraud venues covered by the vac
screening program are required to check
id for those 18 plus
id for 12 plus is optional
the covid safe app allows you to upload
a picture of your id if you don't want
to carry it
so it's easy to work around
it's easy to acquire he says and the
point is to help reduce fraud
g
you don't say
so now
if if the democrats are going to keep up
this line of argument that it is
essential that you get an id an official
new york id a government id in order to
go to a restaurant
in order really to go in anywhere to any
kind of recreational venue
but
it's evil and terrible to make you to
get an id to vote
what you are saying is
that we need to have higher standards
for eating
a sandwich than we have for protecting
our
democratic republic
we need there is a higher standard of
proof required to go
have tapas
on the lower east side
than to protect our constitutional order
this guy mark levine you know you know
what he sounds like to me he sounds like
an extremist
there are a lot of extremists out there
if you turn tune into some british
morning show
i don't even know the name of it they're
really concerned about extremist
language here here's the la if you hear
your kid
using these kinds of words
you better intervene quickly
they're finding these young boys on on
gaming sites and and um can parents look
out for maybe language that they use
young their young sons might be using
science behavior that they might have
yes they can so there are lots of bits
of language that might be red flags
referring to people as normies or as
triggered normies is the word in cells
used for people outside their community
triggered based cucked describing being
red pilled or black pilled which are
words they used to describe being
infiltrated into the ideology and it's
worth saying as well that they see this
as a kind of conduit to other forms of
extremism it isn't completely separate
from far white white nationalists white
supremacist movements they actually
really see it as a slipway so parents
might see a combination of perhaps also
racism creeping in as well the insult
community is a very racist community
this is a racist ideology and of course
white supremacist is a deeply
misogynistic ideology
if your son is not a cuck if he does not
want to be a cuck he might be an
extremist white supremacist my british
accent is getting worse and worse by the
day
as though [ __ ] which is
one of the oldest insults in the world i
mean italians actually have different
symbols they wear it as jewelry the
little horn thing it looks like or the
little the like the rock star symbol
that italians were that's the symbol of
the cornuto of the [ __ ] the cuckold the
idea that your wife is cheating on you
you've got an unfaithful wife this is a
very basic insult there are many of
these others as well but if you use them
some of which are quite dated now
actually your kid is an extremist
no better than a terrorist you've got to
watch out all every all the
conservatives are terrorists
all the leftists wonderful great people
we've got to kick one group out of
society and society's only fit for the
other one you know
this is really getting my blood flowing
my red iron-rich blood because
it's full of iron because of how much i
love good ranchers did you know that
over 80 percent of the grass-fed beef
sold in the united states is imported
from overseas well my friends the good
ranchers have traveled the country on a
mission to help the american family by
working together with local farms and
ranches and shipping straight to your
door
goodranchers.com is a safe and
convenient way to order your meat they
save your family money and they help the
american farmer i was eating good
ranchers just two nights ago i had their
delicious burgers and they were
absolutely magnificent and sweet little
elisa loved them too goodranchers.com
delivers american craft beef and better
than organic chicken they got t-bones
fillets strips gourmet burgers and more
for me i'd go for the strips and the
burgers but your mileage may vary at
half the price of online competitors you
get the steakhouse quality you deserve
whatever cut that you like at a price
that every family can afford go to
goodranchers.com to buy now or subscribe
today save 20 on each box of
mouth-watering meats subscribing brings
the cost down to less than five bucks a
meal plus right now get an additional 20
bucks off and free express shipping if
you go to goodranchers.com knowles use
code knowles at checkout 20 bucks off
and free express shipping at
goodranchers.com knowles know where your
meat comes from with goodranchers.com
also if you're looking for an
alternative to the legacy media that
actually values the truth the daily wire
readers pass is perfect for you just
just four dollars a month you'll unlock
exclusive access to editorial content
that you won't get anywhere else and
right now get a free four-week trial
when you sign up at dailywire.com
subscribe hurry this deal will not last
much longer also
if you watch the matt walsh show you
might have heard that the sweet baby
gang is in need of a sweet baby anthem
this is now your last chance to submit
yours matt's looking for an original
song that embodies the sweet baby gang
all submissions should be in the form of
youtube video links will be judged
american idol style by myself by other
daily wire hosts and you the viewer will
be voting on which song wins submissions
end tomorrow august 25th voting will
take place on labor day tune in to the
matt walsh youtube channel to watch the
judging of the submissions the winner
will be at september 8th on the matt
walsh show this is your last chance go
to dailywire.com sbg to enter we'll be
right back with a lot more
can you believe it's only been what it's
been
about seven months since the attempted
coup d'etat
since the attempt the well-organized
attempt
to
take over the american government we
were this close to tyranny the
insurrection
the worst event since
the war of 1812.
we were told that right we were told
this was directed by trump trump called
for the insurrection it was organized it
was plotted it was a conspiracy by all
the various affair charlie kirk was
probably in alex jones was involved the
jared kushner i don't know all the they
just throw out random names that are in
any way associated with the american
right it was roger stone they all
well the fbi has come out
they've been investigating this thing
and this is according to reuters not
exactly a conservative news website
quote
the fbi has found scant evidence that
the january 6th attack on the u.s
capitol was the result of an organized
plot to overturn the presidential
election result according to four
current and former law enforcement
officials
though federal officials have arrested
more than 570
alleged participants the fbi at this
point believes the violence was not
centrally coordinated by far-right
groups or prominent supporters of then
president donald trump according to the
sources who have been either directly
involved in or briefed regularly on the
wide-ranging investigations
huh
because we we have a january 6th
commission right now you know the big
investigation which is exclusively being
run by democrats democrats in the house
plus two fake republicans liz cheney and
adam kinzinger
who are court jester conservatives whose
whole point is to just sort of prop up
the liberal establishment edifice so
they're telling us we've got to get to
the bottom of this
organized central plot coup d'etat while
the fbi has been investigating too they
say no it's not
it's not quote 90 to 95 percent of these
are one-off cases said a former senior
law enforcement official with knowledge
of the investigation then you have five
percent maybe of these militia groups
that were closely organized but there
was no grand scheme with roger stone and
alex jones and all of these people to
storm the capital and take hostages
this is reuters saying this by the way
so
brings up an important side point but
it's an important one how to read the
news
when
the news is potentially bad
for a republican
and the mainstream establishment media
go easy on it
you can probably believe it because it's
very simple why the the establishment
media take every chance that they can to
attack republicans sometimes they'll
make up negative stories out of whole
cloth so if the establishment media are
going easy on republicans
it means that you can trust the report
because it really means they can't find
anything the same would not be true of
the establishment media going after
democrats
or even some far right-wing media group
there aren't that many of them but going
after democrats right because the
incentives there are such that
they want to find something but but but
in this case
the media they want
to find something about the republicans
they're reporting nicely about them
which means
they don't have it they don't have it's
not
and i
i hate to say i told you so but early on
during the january 6th remember the
worst event said oh yeah this is bad
it's not good it doesn't look good it
obviously didn't accomplish very much
these poor people now are going to rot
in prison that's that's unfortunate i
don't i don't like that which wish we
had done frankly i wish there had been
something a little more coordinated
within the political system that could
have looked into some
discrepancies in georgia or perhaps in
arizona or obviously what happened in
pennsylvania you know i wish it had been
more effective
but but i said the idea that the horn
guy
is leading the insurrection is
preposterous it was laughable at the
time and it remains even more visible
today
what was the they got in right they got
if this were an insurrection and they
really made it in to the capitol and
then they would have formed a new
government
but if they were just some guys in horn
hats dancing around and the smiley guy
with the pelosi lectern then they're not
going to form a new government because
it's not an insurrection which is what
the fbi is has concluded
speaking of regime change
speaking of coup d'etat
larry elder
larry r pal larry elder
looking pretty good in this recall
election in california
we've been talking about the recall for
a long time there's this effort for
years building up now to recall gavin
newsom because he was a terrible
governor
i say with personal first-hand
experience of what a horrible governor
he is i fled the state in part because
of his poor leadership
so there were these
people who were trying to replace him
you had kevin faulconer down there in
san diego i guess a good republican but
he just didn't have the name recognition
or the fundraising ability john cox had
already gotten beaten by by newsome same
thing didn't really raise money didn't
have name recognition
bruce jenner that who's not
really conservative in any meaningful
sense of the term right he said i don't
have any loyalty to the republicans i
don't have any loyalty to trump i'm
mostly focused on the lgbt emphasis on
the t community
to say nothing of the fact that
he clearly has a tenuous relationship
with reality
and very basic questions so that wasn't
going to work that was always a
distraction republicans didn't really
support him
and then larry elder came in larry elder
a little more libertarian than i would
like in my sort of candidate i mean he's
much more libertarian i think than
conservative but he's got some strong
conservative stances i like the guy
pretty straight shooter he would be an
extraordinarily great improvement in
california and and here's what's crucial
he actually has a shot
the way i know he's got a shot
is that the left is taking him really
seriously the way i know he's really got
a shot
is that the left is now calling him a
white supremacist
that's how you know that you you've got
a really strong republican candidate is
when someone who has never been accused
or never been involved in you know
racial terrible things when just out of
the blue
he gets called a white supremacist even
in the case of larry elder if he's a
black guy so
i kid you not this is the headline from
the la times
larry elder
is the black face of white supremacy
you've been warned
he's the black face of don't
don't let his black skin
his upbringing in south central fool you
no no he's a
white supremacist is it even worth
trying to read this article i don't i
don't think so here's one i won't lie
right this person few things infuriate
me more than watching a black person use
willful blindness and cherry-picked
facts to make overly simplistic
arguments that whitewash
the complex problems that come along
with being black in america
few things delight me more than watching
libs
rend their garments and gnash their
teeth
when they face a serious challenge from
a conservative especially in this case a
black conservative because the they'll
call anyone a white supremacist i mean
they called trump a white supremacist
if if i ever run for anything i'm sure
they'll call me a white supremacist
despite my swarthiness they call
everyone a white supremacist
hitler neo-nazi they did it to reagan
they do it to everybody
but it's really funny when they do it to
a black guy right because it's so
preposterous good this is good news for
larry elder
i mean he's
he's doing very well in the polls the
polls are a little weird on this race
because the only poll that really
matters if you're larry elder is whether
you recall or you don't recall
because there's the first question on
the ballot is do you want to recall
newsome yes or no
the next question is who do you want to
replace him larry elder is trouncing
everyone else in the in the who do you
want to replace him part right now so
the only question that matters is yes or
no
if 50 plus one voters say yes
then he's recalled
if
more voters say no
he's not recalled but if he's recalled
larry elder almost certainly will be the
governor the way you know that larry
elder is also in a good position right
now california regulators are trying to
sink his candidacy so not we're not
talking about the political operatives
we're not talking about the
establishment media but i repeat myself
we're talking about
actual officials in the state of
california
who think uh oh yikes
this guy's getting a little too close so
now according to reports
california regulators have launched an
investigation into whether recall
election gubernatorial candidate larry
elder failed to properly disclose his
income sources according to the fair
political practices commission
so this is completely bogus it's
extremely stupid
what they're going to suggest is that
larry elder didn't file some
form that he should have filed and or
maybe he forgot to mention that he wrote
some book or something or that you know
he gave a speech or as he went on tour
or something like that
none of which would have any
relationship to his recall campaign
right this recall campaign's only been
going on for some weeks now it's not
like this guy's been running for years
and years and years trading on his
political influence
but they're going to say no he forgot to
file form 267
so he's out this this is the way the
bureaucracy
clamps down on the will of the people
and on our democratic and republican
systems
they go no you messed up this
technicality you missed it so now we're
going to have to come in and try to
suppress your campaign
this is still good news for larry elder
it means they're genuinely afraid of him
which means that that newsom may well
be voted out of office another terrible
governor just did leave office yesterday
it was yesterday right yeah no today
today is his last day
in office
i think he's officially out
today he's no longer governor
andrew cuomo andrew cuomo just a couple
days ago
was
was
giving a press conference about the
weather basically he was giving a press
conference about these storms and how
new yorkers can prepare for them he was
asked a question obviously about what
people really care about his resignation
and the scandals
and he snapped at the reporter
so yesterday your personal attorney rita
glavin suggested that she had
information that would call into
question charlotte bennett's credibility
why do you think it's appropriate for
your attorney to make those remarks
without providing significant evidence
to back up the claim
yeah you know i don't want to get uh
into albany politics uh which is uh
what has been going on for the past few
months
this is about a storm briefing to save
lives of new yorkers
uh but you're the law journal uh if you
think justice
is to accept a complaint from a person
without investigation
uh and without credibility
determinations and without
looking at
past actions of that person
then you don't know what the justice
system is
i can make a complaint about you
today maybe it's true maybe it's not
true
but that's why they do investigations
every day cuomo is sounding more and
more like a corleone
more and more like a mobster
governor cuomo you're still attacking
your accusers so why do you think that's
possible to do or acceptable to do
without evidence
yeah maybe i
maybe i make a few accusations about you
maybe
that's my father k that's not me
luca brazie came over he's gonna make
you an offer you can't refuse
he says either your signature or your
brains are gonna be on the contract
mr reporter
sad end sad end for andrew cuomo's
political career
i mean it's a happy end i guess for all
of us
on the republican side of the aisle all
of us who want good government in new
york but it is corrupt over there and
you know in fairness to cuomo he's a
pretty crooked guy but
he's not the most crooked guy in albany
i mean all new york state politics is a
very corrupt endeavor so crooked as he
may be
it's that it's that whole swamp it's
that whole just disgusting blob up there
in in new york and they took him down
and that's good that's something worth
celebrating now let's let's do new some
now
that's the next one up everybody we got
one down one to go
speaking of governors who clearly want
to be president
christie gnome
christie gnome is the governor in south
dakota
she
made a big splash during kovid because
she didn't really lock down her state
and that was great stuff i mean she
showed really strong leadership then
people began to speak about her as a
potential presidential candidate she
looks good she talks good she had been
governing quite well
and then she started to go a little bit
squish
so a bill crossed her desk
regarding whether or not men should be
able to compete in women's sports in
schools
and she vetoed it she wouldn't go along
with it
she said it's okay i'm happy to go along
with this and kick the men out of
women's sports k-12 but i'm not willing
to go along with this to kick men out of
women's sports at the college level
and the excuses that were given by her
people is that well you know then we
might lose some ncaa events well then we
might lose some money well maybe you
know that i think what was implied with
some corporations don't feel so happy
about this and so she went a little bit
squishy what i think should be a pretty
simple question a basic question of
principle should
women be allowed to be a separate
category from men should women be
accepted as
their own
category with their own bathrooms with
their own sports or not and christine
omg squish so now she's come out and she
said if joe biden illegally mandates
vaccines i will take every action
available under the law to protect south
dakotans from the federal government
well that's good i'm glad that she's
doing that but i think there's reason
for skepticism because back
last february in february of 2020
she
had the opportunity
to sign a bill that would prevent
vaccine mandates by schools and she
refused to do it and she came out very
strongly in favor of vaccine mandates by
schools and i get why she did it
there's a long history in the united
states of schools mandating certain
vaccines and she said so vaccines are
good some vaccines obviously are good
and so i'm going to stand by those
vaccine mandates now she's coming out
saying if biden illegally mandates
vaccines
i'm going to take every action available
under the law to protect south dakotans
well what changed
what changed and will she really do it
i'm not so sure
i don't mean to cast any aspersions you
know at christie gnome or anyone else
but when we're talking about who is
going to be
the republican standard-bearer in 2024
we're going to need more than pretty
talk
we're going to need a record we're going
to need concrete actions we're going to
need to know somebody because now
everyone is trying to talk like trump
now everyone is trying to talk nice and
tough and don't forget the people who
become governor
senator presidential candidates
these are very good politicians these
are varsity level politicians who can
really tell which way the wind is
blowing
much better than than other people can
and and they're going to change the way
they speak as a result but are they
going to change their behavior do they
have credibility are they going to
follow through
that i don't know i'd almost have more
respect for christinoma she came out and
said
look
some vaccines are good i think it's
totally right for schools to mandate the
pertussis vaccine for instance whooping
cough but this vaccine was obviously
hastily developed it's still an
experimental drug it's to fight of a
virus that is not particularly dangerous
to most people and so and especially not
particularly dangerous to kids and so
we're not going to mandate it she got
into the specifics and explained why she
would vote for one thing but not for the
other i'm i'm cool with that i think
that's actually a good exercise in
judgment and political leadership
but if it's just going to be pretty
words that's not going to work in
2024
speaking of
mandates
the american bar association
this is the organization of lawyers the
organization
that
is is
involved in
accredited law schools
is now mandating
diversity training and affirmative
action according to reports
the american bar association is applies
to mandate diversity training and
affirmative action at all of its
accredited law schools says one report a
move top legal scholars say could
jeopardize academic freedom and for
schools to violate federal law they'd be
violating federal law by taking race
into account in things like admissions
schools would be required to quote take
effective actions to quote diversify
their student bodies even when doing so
risks violating a law that performs to
prohibit consideration of race
or ethnicity
shows you how the game is stacked shows
you how there's no neutrality
in the law
and not just in the law but in the
organization that kind of runs the law
in the organization of the lawyers and
that
that shapes the law schools
they are now going to weigh in on the
side of radical leftist policy
in violation
of the law
in some cases
how strange
for the
squishy republicans the squishy
conservatives who who believe that
somehow secular liberalism is a neutral
playing ground and we've all got to stop
making substantive arguments about how
we want the country to be running we
only should be making these sort of
procedural arguments and all we should
only be just talking about how wonderful
it is to have debate and and openness
and no we have to be able to stand for
certain things as i've said until i'm
blue in the face
we need to be able to say no
considering race
in admissions and in hiring is wrong
disadvantaging whites and asians because
they they have the wrong color skin and
advantaging
giving an advantage to black and
hispanic applicants just because they
have the right color skin is wrong we're
not going to do it we're going to stand
against that not only are we going to
leave it an open question but we're
actively going to prohibit that kind of
stuff
that's what we need to do
is if you don't if you don't actually
stand for certain things which means
encouraging the good and suppressing the
bad
then you're not just going to be left in
this neutral playing ground if
everything's up in the air you're going
to
seed the ground to the left which is
willing to institute what it wants the
former attorney general eric holder says
people need to get out in the streets
in raising the consciousness of people
by demonstrating by getting arrested by
doing the things that ended segregation
if you ask people back in the 1950s you
think marching demonstrating is going to
bring down a system of american
apartheid you probably would have said
no that's just not going to happen and
we should not lose faith right now we
shouldn't lose faith right now citizens
can make a change citizens need to be in
the streets citizens need to be
demonstrating citizens need to be
calling their representatives to demand
the kind of change
that will make this country more
representative make our democracy more
fair that's barack obama's corrupt
biased crooked attorney general eric
holder who is not talking about
segregation who is not talking about
anything involving civil rights in the
mid 20th century he's talking about a
law right now that would federalize
elections give
up end this constitutional order and
give give already sitting elected
politicians a huge advantage to keep at
anyone who wants to challenge them so
corrupt and he's saying get out in the
streets get out in the streets
just like so many democrat politics go
get out in the streets and pressure them
and threaten them and intimidate
everyone in this country into doing what
you want them to do we can't have that
we can't have a country like that
country seems to be disintegrating all
around not just in afghanistan but here
as well and can you even imagine under
the potential
president harris i'm michael moses
michael nolshow seymour
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boris our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
today on the ben shapiro show joe biden
believes if he yells at americans about
covert they will forget about
afghanistan plus the biden
administration continues to downplay the
ongoing crisis in afghanistan that's
today on the ben shapiro show give it a
listen